GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
WELCOME TO OUR THANKSGIVING FAN
MAIL EXTRAVAGANZA, YOUR
QUESTIONS FOR THE ENTIRE HOUR ON
THIS VERY SPECIAL EDITION OF
"THE FIVE."
GRAB THOSE STRETCH PANTS AND OF
THE DRUMSTICK AND LET'S BEGIN.
FIRST QUESTION, INSTAGRAM
QUESTION.
IF YOU WERE A CHARACTER, GREG,
I'M ON A FLOAT IN THE
THANKSGIVING PARADE, WHAT WOULD
YOU BE?
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
I GUESS I -- WHAT'S A FLOAT?
I'VE NEVER BEEN TO A
THANKSGIVING DAY PARADE.
I GUESS I'D BE SNOOPY.
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE ONLY
CHARACTER YOU KNOW.
>> Greg: I HAVEN'T SEEN A
FLOAT SINCE I WAS THREE.
PARADES ARE TERRIBLE FOR SHORT
PEOPLE.
>> Dana: DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
HAVE AT THE MACY'S DAY PARADE
NOW?
ELF ON A SHELF.
>> Greg: SOMETHING YOU CAN
LOOK UP TO.
THE CRUELEST PEOPLE ABOUT HYATT
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SHORTER.
>> Dana: I WOULD BE ON ANY OF
THE FLOATS THAT WOULD HAVE THE
COUNTRY MUSIC BANDS PLAYING.
>> Jesse: WANT, YOU LOOK
DISGUSTED.
A >> Juan: I CAN'T BELIEVE
GREG NEVER WENT TO A
THANKSGIVING DAY PARADE.
>> Greg: I GREW UP ON THE
WEST COAST, WE DIDN'T HAVE THOSE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT HURTS THE EARTH AND THE BUGS
AND THE CRICKETS.
I AM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, WE
DON'T HAVE PARADES.
WE HAVE CERTAIN PARADES.
BUT BEING SHORT, YOU CAN'T SEE
BEHIND PEOPLE SO WHAT'S THE
POINT?
I'M NOT GOING TO SIT ON
SHOULDERS LIKE LAST YEAR.
>> Juan: I WOULD WANT MY
GRANDKIDS TO WATCH ME, THEIR
FAVORITES ARE LADYBUGS, MY
GRANDSON LIKES TIN TIN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE A FLOA
FLOAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS A FLOAT
AND WHAT ISN'T BUT IF IF THERE'S
A SUPERHERO FLOAT --
>> Dana: THEY'VE GOT THAT.
>> I COULD BE SPIDER-MAN.
>> Greg: BREAK OUT OF YOUR
BOXES.
>> Jesse: I WOULDN'T BE A
FLOAT, I WOULD BE THE
GRAND MARSHAL.
NEXT QUESTION FROM GREG'S
FAVORITE PERSON ON INSTAGRAM,
WHAT'S YOUR BEST FUNNY SNOW
STORY IN NEW YORK CITY?
FUNNIEST NEW YORK CITY SNOW
STORY?
>> Jedediah: MY FAVORITE SNOW
STORIES ALL INVOLVE ME FALLING.
WE WENT SLEDDING AND I HAD THE
SLED UPSIDE DOWN.
I LOST THE RACE BIG.
BUT I DID MAKE GREAT SNOWMAN.
>> Jesse: BETTER LUCK NEXT
TIME.
>> Juan: IT REMINDS ME OF WHEN
"THE FIVE" WENT SLEDDING IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I THINK DANA WON.
>> Dana: I CAME IN SECOND.
I WILL TELL YOU, GREG LOST.
HE IS FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED HE DIDN'T HAVE
EXPERIENCE SLEDDING.
>> Greg: NO SNOW, NO PARADES.
NO SLEDS.
>> Jedediah: NO FUN.
>> Juan: LAST WEEK WE HAD A
SURPRISE SNOWSTORM IN NEW YORK.
YOU COULDN'T GET ANY CAR SERVIC
SERVICE, FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: I COULDN'T GET
CAVIAR.
>> Juan: I HAD TO WALK FROM MY
HOTEL TO PENN STATION TO GET ON
THE TRAIN, I AM FALLING DOWN
LIKE JEDEDIAH.
I RAN INTO JOE BIDEN, HE WAS
HAVING THE SAME TROUBLE.
>> Jesse: THAT REMINDS ME, I
THINK IT WAS A SNOW DAY HERE IN
THE CITY, I LIVED IN LONG ISLAND
AND SO DID O'REILLY, I CALLED
OUT BECAUSE I SAID I COULDN'T
MAKE IT INTO THE CITY AND HE
STILL MADE IT IN AND I NEVER
HEARD THE END OF THAT.
DANA?
>> Dana: I HAVE A FEW FALLING
ONES.
OVER AT THE PARK, I FELL DOWN,
GOT UP, FELL DOWN.
I REMEMBER ABOUT SEVEN YEARS
AGO, THE STORMS WE HAD
BACK-TO-BACK END OF THE SNOW
DIDN'T MELT FOR A COUPLE MONTHS?
I LIVED IN D.C. BUT I WAS UP
HERE AND I ENDED UP STAYING AT
THE MUSE HOTEL FOR ABOUT SIX
DAYS BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T GET
ANYWHERE AROUND THE CITY, YOU
COULDN'T GET BACK TO D.C., SO I
DID A LOT OF FOX NEWS.
>> Jesse: THAT IS A GREAT SNOW
STORY.
>> Greg: MY GREATEST SNOW
STORY WAS A COUPLE YEARS AGO,
THIS HORRIBLE EVENT CALLED SANTA
CON, THEY GO PUB CRAWLING AND
GET REALLY WASTED.
I WAS WITH A BUDDY, WE WERE IN
THIS GREAT BAR ON THIRD AND
AND AVENUE THAT HAD A SIGN THAT
SAID NO SANTOS AND ALL THESE
DRUNK SANTAS WERE OUTSIDE
SCREAMING AND BANGING ON THE
WINDOW, WE WERE ON THE INSIDE
DRINKING AND LAUGHING AND YOU
WALK OUT AND THEY ARE ALL REALLY
ANNOYING PEOPLE, THANKFULLY
SANTA CON HAS PRETTY MUCH DIED
OUT.
IT'S THE WORST THING THAT IS
HAPPENED TO NEW YORK CITY SINCE
BILL de BLASIO.
>> Jesse: ISN'T THERE
SOMETHING CALLED "BAD SANTA"
THAT'S A MOVIE?
>> Jesse: FOR ALL THE KIDS
WATCHING, SANTA IS REAL.
IF YOU COULD BE A THANKSGIVING
SIDE DISH, WHAT WOULD YOU BE AND
WHY, DANA?
>> Dana: I LOVE THE
CRANBERRIES.
I WORE A CRANBERRY COLORED
SWEATER.
I PUT SOME THOUGHT INTO THIS.
>> Jesse: AND I CAN?
>> Dana: $1.89?
>> Jesse: SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: I'D BE GRAVY BECAUSE
THEN I WOULD BE ALL OVER YOUR
MEAT.
>> Juan: OH, MY GOD, .
YOU'VE GOT TO BE THE STUFFING.
IT'S THE ONLY TIME OF YEAR I EAT
STUFFING.
>> Jesse: DO YOU TO THE
STUFFING ON THE BIRD THE BURNER
INSIDE?
>> Juan: IT HAS TO BE ON THE
INSIDE.
>> Greg: MIND COMES FROM A
BOX.
>> Jedediah: THE STUFFING IS A
BEST PART, THROW EVERYTHING
TOGETHER AND IT'S JUST BREAD,
ALL THE STUFF YOU'RE REALLY NOT
SUPPOSED TO EAT BUT YOU REALLY
WANT TO EAT.
>> Greg: I GET IT FROM
UNDERNEATH THE SOFA CUSHIONS
WHEN I MAKE IT.
I'D BE THE MASHED POTATOES, HOLD
THE GRAVY.
INSTAGRAM QUESTION, WHO IS YOUR
FAVORITE RELATIVE AND WHY?
>> Dana: THAT'S DANGEROUS.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHO IS YOUR
FAVORITE RELATIVE?
>> Juan: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
SAYING THAT I WAS YOUR FAVORITE
RELATIVE.
>> Jesse: WE ARE RELATED.
>> Juan: I ALWAYS THOUGHT
MAXINE AND YOU WERE RELATED TO.
>> Jesse: VACCINE IS NOT
COMING FOR THANKSGIVING AND IF
SHE DID SHE WOULD CHASE ME OUT
OF THE RESTAURANT.
>> Juan: SHEET SUBPOENA YOU.
I'D GUESS I'D HAVE TO SAY MY
WIFE.
IS SHE MY RELATIVE?
>> Jesse: UNLESS THERE IS --
>> Juan: IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
THE GRANDKIDS THE GRANDKIDS.
>> Jesse: ALL OF THEM?
>> Juan: YES.
>> Jedediah: I'M GOING TO SAY
MY MOM.
IF I DON'T SAY HER SHE WOULD BE
REALLY MAD.
SHE'S THE COOLEST MOM EVER.
>> Jesse: I SAW YOUR MOM ON
"FOX & FRIENDS."
>> Jedediah: SHE'S PRETTY
COOL.
I WILL BE WELL FED AND I WANT TO
ANGER ANYONE, IT'S A GOOD
ANSWER.
>> Jesse: I WILL HAVE TO GO
WITH MOM, TOO.
SHE COOKS.
>> Dana: AND SHE TEXTS.
I AM GOING TO HAVE TO GO WITH
THE AUNTS, AUNT PATTY SUE AND
AUNT DONNA.
>> Greg: WE HAVE 13 NIECES AND
NEPHEWS ALL ATE BETWEEN THE AGE
OF 5-8, I WILL SAY BOB, THE
OTHER ONES ARE SMELLY, THEY ARE
KIND OF STUPID, A LOT OF THESE
NIECES AND NEPHEWS ARE REALLY
DUMB.
BUT BOB IS OKAY.
>> Jesse: THIS ONE IS FROM
NATALIE, WHAT'S THE BIGGEST
THANKSGIVING FAIL YOU'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED?
FAIL.
IN THE KITCHEN OR TOAST THAT
WENT REALLY WRONG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> Jedediah: I COOKED ONE YEAR
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT'S NOT A
GOOD SIGN, I AM A TERRIBLE CHEF,
EVERYONE WAS LIKE "YOU CAN DO
IT" TURNS OUT I COULDN'T DO IT,
THE TURKEY WAS DRY, IF THE
TURKEY IS DRY -- EVERYBODY BUT
SIDES AND THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD
SO IT WORKED OUT ALL RIGHT.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
SOMETHING I DID BUT WHENEVER
ANYBODY BRINGS CREAM TO DISH,
CREAMED CAULIFLOWER, CREAMED
ONIONS.
THIS IS NASTY.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THAT.
>> Dana: WHEN I WAS 17 FOR A
YEAR I HAD CHRONIC STREP THROAT
AND FINALLY MY PARENTS FOUND A
DOCTOR, A SURGEON WHO WOULD TAKE
MY TONSILS OUT, THE ONLY DAY WE
COULD GET IT DONE WAS WEDNESDAY,
THE DAY BEFORE THANKSGIVING.
SO I COULDN'T EAT ANYTHING BUT I
COULD SMELL IT ALL.
THAT WAS A BIG FAIL.
>> Greg: IT HAD TO BE WHEN WE
KILLED UNCLE FRANK.
THAT'S THE NAME FOR A PLANT WE
HAVE IN THE LIVING ROOM.
I'VE BEEN RAISING BOB ON MY OWN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jesse: I WENT TO THE WRONG
HOUSE ON THANKSGIVING, I WAS
CONFUSED.